[Music]
not going here I'm rollin a minute
somersault
I sustained Kazushi pattern so Full Tilt
now I gotta go across the hip not over
here his head is across the hip Oh Oh
his head keep going down not I don't do
that
I just hold it here projects across do
not push the head if I push the head I
push the whole ex powdered away from me
I don't have that expertise I think
crossed the head but I push the head
line away from me so intense days why me
and then reject this true do not take
the whole body
[Music]
I have my going there but it's not be
pushing it it's just a connection but
you keep racing wait the same way you
race on your feet all right that's not
so you're on your knees to do detox
okay go to standing this leg is going to
be harder for you scaredy cats
the Kazushi is easier and the fall is
higher but it's still vectoring